this is a great story to not only communicate
to you things going on in the real world,
but also to talk about how narratives are
created and framed by corporate media.
So listen, basically support for impeaching.
Donald Trump went up when a news of the Ukraine
fiasco first broke hitting about 46 47% and
then throughout everything that we've seen
happen publicly related to Ukraine and Trump,
so far as support for impeachment has crept
up to 50% 52% 55% depending on which poll
look at.
Now, that by itself is big news.
This is a lot more impeachment support than
there was for Richard Nixon early in Watergate.
It's not normal when it comes to previous
presidents.
Obama, Bush, as much as Obama and Bush were
hated by the right and left respectively.
You didn't have more than half the country
saying that the president should be impeached
when it was Obama and Bush.
So now we have a new poll.
The poll happens to be from Fox news of all
places, and it says, indeed, 54% of the country
wants Donald Trump impeached.
Now, you might notice that I'm leaving out
a piece of information here, and I did it
on purpose for the, uh, for the, for the purposes
of our story today, I did this deliberately.
When I say 54% of the country wants Trump
impeached.
If you are a media literate individual, if
you're a savvy thinker, you should be saying,
does David mean 54% want Trump impeached by
the house or is David saying 54% want Trump
impeached and removed via a conviction in
the Senate?
That is the right question to be asking and
that is exactly the game that is being played
with these numbers.
The game that's being played in lots of corporate
media is that they aren't specifying clearly
whether by impeachment people understand that
to mean or are meaning to say that they want
the house to impeach and a trial in the Senate
whose outcome could be one thing or the other
thing.
Or are people saying when they say they want
to impeach, we want Trump convicted and removed
by the Senate.
In this poll, 54% want Trump impeached.
50% want Trump impeached and removed.
Meaning that there is 4% in there that want
Trump impeached in the house but not necessarily
removed by the Senate.
So this is already one game that can be played.
You can talk about support is up versus support
is down, but by not specifying whether you're
talking about impeachment only or impeachment
and removal, you can kind of pick whichever
result is closer to suiting your view in the
narrative you want to craft.
This is how you simultaneously had some networks
saying impeachment hearings have destroyed
support for Trump impeachment and you had
other media outlets saying support for impeachment
is up.
Since the hearings have started, if you want
to say support for impeachment is growing,
you choose a poll that shows it, even if it's
just for articles of impeachment and not removal
or vice versa.
I think that you understand the other game
that is being played is the momentum game
after hearing started.
Right?
Wow.
The hearings have really deflated the impeachment
movement.
And then at the other time you have some saying,
wow, the hearings are really growing support
for Trump impeachment.
Now, how could both be true?
Just look at different polls.
So the real story is not the two to three
points swings and impeachment support because
that's all that we're seeing.
Tons of people don't even know what's going
on or at least aren't paying attention daily.
So the real story here is roughly half the
country wants Trump impeached and removed
the numbers going up and down to three points.
That's really not a big deal.
What's not normal is that half the country
wants the president impeached and removed.
But most importantly, if you look at the internals
of the polls, there's a big polling gap in
favor of impeachment.
If I only tell you 50% wants Trump removed,
you might assume, Oh, so 50% does not want
from removed.
It's dead even it's an even split wrong.
Lots of people respond that they don't know
or they aren't sure.
So in the Fox news poll, 50% want him impeached
and removed.
4% want him just impeached and 41% say don't
impeach.
That means it is not 50 50 it is a plus 13
the people that want an impeachment versus
the people that do not.
That's huge.
That's what really matters.
Do not be tricked by crafty reporting into
taking your eye off of the ball, which is
that half the country wants Trump removed
and there is a plus 13 gap of people that
want impeachment over people that do not.
It won't change whether it happens of course,
but don't fall for the games that the corporate
media is playing around impeachment polls.